here it is here was kamala harris
you know playing the victim card here
she was claiming that mike pence
was mansplaining to her it's so terrible
he's interrupting here we go
the vice president said when asked well
why didn't you all tell anybody
he said because the president wanted
people to remain
calm well let's go no but susan i this
is important
and i want to add mr vice president i'm
speaking i have i'm speaking
okay now what's amazing there is that
page jumps in
and interrupts harris right she says mr
vice president because she wants him to
answer the charge
and pence then follows up on paige
saying
okay i'd like to answer that and she and
she immediately jumps to
i'm speaking here this is my floor i'm
speaking here
okay here's the deal that is called like
a normal debate and susan page was the
first person to interrupt kamala harris
in that tweet
in that in that particular clip the
first time she brings out and she kept
bringing up this gun throughout the
debate
whenever she felt she was losing she
went to i'm trying to speak here i want
my time okay here's
after after all the time was was counted
up actually there were a couple
different estimates
at the very least she got equal time
with pence and by some counts she got
three minutes more than pens
but apparently she was victimized i mean
that clip is astonishing paige is the
one
who jumps in and then pen says okay now
it's my time no no i'm still speaking mr
vice president i am speaking here i am
speaking
you're gonna have to pick one again
women are fully
empowered it is wonderful that we have
female vp candidates they should be
treated just the same as everyone else
or women must be treated as though they
are
weak creatures incapable of handling a
a mild-mannered vice president saying to
them
i'd like to answer that please i mean
that's literally what my pen says
he says i'd like to respond like
i'm sorry that and as we'll see this
became the media narrative it's really
really incredible
okay back to the debate so kamala harris
starts talking with mike pence about
about vaccines
and she's asked directly if she will
take a vaccine and she keeps trotting
out this nonsensical line about vaccines
where she says well if donald trump
tells me to take a vaccine i won't but
if doctors tell me to take a vaccine i
will what do you think donald trump is
down in the basement cooking up the
serum
you think donald trump is like taking
antibodies out of his own body and then
he's making a virus an antivirus
like will smith and i am legend like
that's how this is all going here kamal
harris
or is it true that under the trump
administration operation warp speed is
developing a vaccine faster than any
vaccine has been developed in human
history
and that he deserves some credit for
that this is such a nonsensical and
silly line here is harris talking about
vaccines
you respect the american people when you
tell them the truth if the
public health professionals if dr fauci
if
the doctors tell us that we should take
it i'll be the first in line to take it
absolutely but if donald trump tells us
i should
that we should take it i'm not taking it
okay i have a question does she actually
think that donald trump is going to be
out there
like okay you know this vaccine all my
doctors are rejecting go take it right
now
right now hey mike pence properly calls
her up well calls her out on this and uh
and kamal smirks throughout again her
performance last night was abysmal
the media are trying to save her from
herself they've been trying to do it for
literally years at this point when she
dropped out of the race we got a bevy of
articles
about what a wondrous wondrous candidate
she was if she was so wondrous
why was she so terrible here's kamala
smirking as mike pence calls out the
point
which is that she is actively dissuading
people from taking a vaccine that we
will need people to take
the reality is that we're going to have
a vaccine
senator in record time in unheard of
time in less than a year
we have five companies in phase three
clinical trials
and we're right now producing tens of
millions of doses
so the fact that you continue to
undermine public confidence in a vaccine
if the vaccine emerges during the trump
administration i think is
is unconscionable and senator i i just
ask you
stop playing politics with people's
lives
okay he is right about this and kamala
harris couldn't stop smirking throughout
okay
when this goes back to al gore it's not
a sexist point that people shouldn't
smirk while they're on split screens
smirking and shaking your head on split
screens looks bad kind of shaking your
head
ruefully doesn't look bad in a split
screen smirking
looks terrible it looks smug and it
looks obnoxious
kamala harris was all of those things
last night okay then they got to the
issue of taxation so
recognize the first like third of the
debate was all about covid
and harris basically her line was that
trump knew in late january early
february this thing was airborne and it
was dangerous
even bob woodward who revealed that in
his book right that trump had said that
sort of stuff
even bob woodward said publicly
interviews we talked about it at the
time
he said i didn't believe that trump knew
all that i thought trump was just
bloviating
because again nobody knew that there was
not a single doctor including fauci who
was saying in early february the thing
was airborne and that it was really
dangerous for young people as it turns
out it is not particularly dangerous to
young people
and even now there is controversy about
just how airborne the virus is
right the cdc literally this week this
week came out with information
suggesting there might be an airborne
component to this
this week the cdc said this it is now
september it is not late january
okay so she relied a lot on bob
woodward's book for
various items of information but then
they moved beyond coven they got into
taxes and here
here is where the debate really started
to go sideways for harris so to this
point
you could say that harris sort of held
her own because on covet the fact is
that the
trump administration's rhetoric has been
bad and the trump administration's
performance has been pretty good because
pence
is rhetorically much better than trump
especially this kind of stuff
he made the record look as good as you
can make it when you have a president
who is doing all the things that
president trump is doing then they got
to the economy and this is where it all
starts to fall apart
for kamala harris so she starts talking
about she she starts talking
about the issue of the economy it's clip
eight
uh she says that there could not be a
more fundamental difference on the issue
of the economy
and in this particular segment of the
debate i mean this was a car crash this
was an absolute car crash
this was a smart car against a big rig
it just did not go well for kamal harris
here here was harris trying to go off on
pence's economy the depends trump
economy the trump pence economy
and uh as you will see pence just was
not having it
on the issue of the economy i think
there couldn't be a more fundamental
difference
between donald trump and joe biden
joe biden believes you measured the
health and the strength of america's
economy
based on the health and the strength of
the american worker
and the american family on the other
hand you have donald trump
who measures the strength of the economy
based on how rich people are doing
on day one joe biden will repeal that
tax bill he'll get rid of it
okay and then and then as you will see
as you'll see mike pence just handed her
hat to her and it's it's
really bad so she says again again
for the 90th time that the first day
biden is going to repeal
trump's tax cuts there's only one
problem with that when you say he's
going gonna repeal the tax cuts
as it turns out you're raising
everybody's taxes okay so kamala harris
suggests that the trump economy is bad
and that trump only cares about the
wealthy
and pence just just destroys her on it
despite what uh senator harris says the
average american family of four
had two thousand dollars in savings in
taxes the average household income for a
family of four
increased by four thousand dollars
following president trump's tax cuts
but america you just heard senator
harris tell you on day one
joe biden's going to raise your taxes
okay and as you and then she starts
smirking
and you get the kamala harris giggle uh
the weird strange joker giggly
okay and then she again she knows she's
caught every time she was caught last
night she played the i'm a woman stop
interrupting me card
all right she woman explained to mike
pence about how debate is not supposed
to be debate as long as a woman
is there i do find by the way all this
mansplaining women are victims stuff
pretty amusing from a party that
suggests that men can be women
that gender is completely a social
construct and women do not exist in fact
men and women are arbitrary categories
decided by society rather than by
biology which means that i suppose that
kamala harris could mansplain to mike
pence anytime she pleases simply by
identifying as a man but in any case
here was kamala harris trying to walk
back the simple fact which is
if you repeal trump's tax cuts then you
end up repealing tax cuts
for 82 of americans who received the tax
cut
here was heroes kamala harris trying to
walk it back and then pence tries to
interject and once again she does the
you're interrupting me you know stop
interrupting me
here she was joe biden has been very
clear
he will not raise taxes on anybody who
makes less than four hundred thousand
dollars a year appeal the trump tax cuts
mr vice president i'm speaking
well i'm speaking be important if you
said the truth
joe biden said twice in the debate last
week that he's going to repeal the trump
tax cuts that was tax cuts that gave the
average working family
two thousand dollars in a tax break
every single year that senator
that is absolutely not true that is he
only cutting
is he only going to repeal part of the
trump tax cuts if you don't mind letting
me finish
we can then have a conversation okay
please okay
again she like she gets caught out and
she has nowhere to go this is another
aspect of her performance last night she
kept basically saying i want my time
back i want my time let me answer and
then she'd get she joe biden did this in
debate too early on he would do this
routine where he's like
i'm not finished yet i want to say my
piece and then everybody would stop
and be like
[Music]
yeah and that's what she did that's the
best part she's like i'd like to finish
her i'd like to finish
and then he says okay let go and she's
like uh
but i was basically like i mean can we
all just acknowledge that what i was
really doing here was just trying to
call you a sexist like can we really
acknowledge that
okay then pence continued to hammer home
this point i mean on the economy he just
he had her debtor rights on the economy
uh so he continued to hammer home this
point uh she was
saying again that that she was not going
to raise taxes that she
and and biden will not raise taxes on
people which of course is a lie
also she was saying that she's not going
to ban fracking joe biden has said it
repeatedly that he looks to get rid of
fracking
she herself has said repeatedly that she
is looking to get rid of fracking
even the fact checkers who some who
somehow suggest
that the biden harris campaign is only
looking to get rid of new leases on
public land
are failing to recognize that all that
harris and biden have been saying the
whole time
is that that is a transitional plan for
getting rid of fossil fuels entirely i
mean they've been very consistent on
this point
here was mike pence hammering this home
you're entitled to your own opinion but
you're not entitled to your own facts
you yourself said on multiple occasions
when you were running for president
that you would ban fracking joe biden
looked at a supporter in the eye
and pointed and said i guarantee i
guarantee
that we will abolish fossil fuels they
have a two trillion dollar version of
the green new deal susan that your
newspaper usa today said
really wasn't that very different from
the original green new deal
is a prescription for economic decline
president trump and i will keep
america growing the v-shaped recovery
that's underway
right now will continue with four more
years of president donald trump
again kamala hairs look terrible on the
split screen because she kept breaking
out the smirk
and the laughter that is every interview
she has ever done when she breaks that
out she's losing
and she was losing last night and losing
badly he kept also
hammering home on the green new deal so
so paige susan page
asked asked kamala harris about joe
biden and the green new deal this was
actually a very good question from susan
page the first time i've seen them
called on it in which she says you know
joe biden denied that he's in favor of
the green new deal
his website literally describes the
green new deal so what's
the deal here what's the deal and then
pence doubles down on it harris
i gotta say i'm not sure which was more
stunning
how well pence performed or how badly
harris performed
i think probably the latter because
expectations for harris were much higher
than expectations for pence
but uh she it was a mismatch last night
it was
this was this was a heavyweight with a
lightweight it was that simple
she has knowledge of issues that goes
about half an inch deep and it does not
go a mile wide
facts don't care about your feelings and
it's a fact that the ben shapiro show is
the largest conservative podcast in the
nation
be sure to hit the subscribe button to
stay up to date on all of our content